[Musik]
hallo dazu kommen zufällig welt heute
gibt es ein leckeres burger rezept und
zwar werde ich einen cheeseburger machen
und dafür habe ich bereits meine
ballwanz also die bürger brötchens
vorbereitet da gibt's auch im konzept
auf meinem kamera da könnt ihr auf jeden
fall mal vorbeischauen wenn das lohnt
sich auf jeden fall heute mache ich den
friedberger das heißt ich werde es eine
ziemlich große zubereiten und später
dann bieten hackfleisch partie mit käse
überbacken mit richtig lecker vor allem
mit den kranken bringen
ich bin jetzt mal sagen wir starten
direkt mit der tomaten chili sauce und
ich zeige mich mal die zutaten für die
türe klose brauche 500 gramm tomaten mit
cocktailtomaten einen teelöffel oregano
triebe 50 meter 80 25 gramm braunem
zucker einen halben teelöffel salz einer
prise pfeffer drei chilischoten hier
habe ich ein paar gewürze und war eine
prise einen halben teelöffel
selbstherrlich spieler fans nahmen einen
esslöffel olivenöl und etwas partner
erste mal nehme ich jetzt die tomaten
und die werden jetzt einfach gefüttert
oder auch nur halb wird die werden doch
so eingebrochen und haben es ist
wirklich egal
das geht entweder so oder nehmt einfach
zwei teller die möglichst gleich groß
sind
da kommen die tomaten rein und dann kann
ich viel mit einem küchenmesser auf
einmal durchschneiden
die tomaten kommen jetzt schon mal in
einen kleinen topf und jetzt kann ich
schon mal hier den herd an machen so
dass das ganze auf kocht und in der
zwischenzeit auch schon mal die zwiebel
schälen und schneiden
sieben jetzt mit tomaten und da kann es
ganz gut umrühren und etwa 10 minuten
kochen lassen bis die automatischen weiß
bringt
während die tomaten noch jahren kann ich
schon mal direkt beim hersteller dafür
frau ist hier nur vier zutaten uns haben
wir zwei ziele und bereits geschält die
schneide ich inhalt ringen habe ich 50
zambrotta 50 gramm und etwas mehl ist
670 gramm
ich werde jetzt nämlich verlieren damit
wirklich die stadt groß werden dass die
zwiebel halbieren
an den hals geschlagen und dann in mehl
wenden
[Applaus]
ich gebe jetzt die butter und das rapsöl
in einer pfanne dann nämlich jetzt nur
eisenbahner und fangen jetzt an zu
weinen und auch im kopf zu einem rein
damit die butter nicht verbrennt das
heißt ich kann das ganze auch dann gut
erhitzen
ihr könnt aber zu lassen auch einfach
butterschmalz nehmen so ich würde es
jedoch kurz interviews mit tränen
wegwischen
wer hab ich jetzt auch mittel hoher
hitze erwärmt und jetzt über die geringe
rein
jetzt werden sie einfach so lange darin
frittiert sozusagen bis sie schön
knusprig sind in der zwischenzeit kann
ich jetzt schon mal die tomaten
passieren das mache ich jetzt einfach
durch ein kleines haus da kommen einfach
dieser tomaten haut respekt
die erste passion zwiebel ist jetzt
fertig tomaten habe ich passiert wieso
seid keine zivilprozess in den topf und
jetzt werde ich hier noch die chili
schoten fein hacken
unternehmt ihr jetzt wenn ihr es
wirklich schlafen möchte wirklich gerne
drei oder vier und wenn es nicht so
scharf sein soll lässt noch keine
natürlich los feliz kommen jetzt mit
soße und genauso auch die restlichen als
oregano oder auch gar noch brauner
zucker salz und die gewürze und ich
schmecke das ganze noch mit muss graf
[Applaus]
ich könnte wetten oder mitunter zum
beispiel nehmen
das ganze ist einfach noch mal
eingekocht das olivenöl gebe ich dann
ganz zum schluss nur die soße darf jetzt
auf kochen und dann für etwa 15 minuten
lang eine jacke aus der küche raus wo
die soße fertig und ich hab dir nochmal
mit bisschen weise abgeschmeckte waren
bis hin zu süßlich jetzt zum schluss
gebe ich noch das öl mit rein
ich bin starken zentrums von von süßen
sohn hat ihr schreckliches als maja und
willi sowieso alles daran die hier ich
glaube hier wirst du auch vor allem in
verbindung mit dem ganzen körper samt
abdecken
die zwiebeln sind schon groß mach mal
probieren aber noch nicht gesagt wie
gross heisst brechen durch bietet genau
und jetzt ist die pegi dran das heißt
das fleisch dafür habe ich jetzt hier
ein bisschen fleisch und zwar in der
natur beim fleisch ist es ganz wichtig
das soll jetzt nicht zu mager sein damit
der bürger einfach nicht betroffen wird
das heißt so 25 prozent fettanteil wer
wirklich so das mindeste und auch
wirklich ideal
tun wir auch schon zusammen bleiben dass
es zu trocken ist dann fällt auch
auseinander und der geschmack kommt halt
einfach durchsetzt ich werde das ganze
jetzt durch wolfen und hab ich da vorne
eine mittelgroße scheibe kommt es hier
oben reinrutschen kalt sein uns am
besten durch wolfen haben und jetzt
immer rein geben die kleinen stücke und
der fleischwolf lässt sie dann die
stücke
das heißt es ist auch gar nicht stopfen
und drücken normal wenn es nicht runter
will zwar kein fan mit dem sofa
nachhelfen
ansonsten kommt von allein erzeugt immer
glück freigestellt ihr könnt hier auch
ein bisschen schneller oder gibt ein
weniger schnell stellen
das heißt ihr bestimmt wie schnell das
fleisch vorne raus kommt und da ist es
egal ob mat oder die tricks
ich habe jetzt innerhalb von 12 minuten
das fleisch gemacht ein kino und jetzt
nehmt ihr eine portion heraus das heißt
ihr könnt entweder mit der hand formen
was ich ganz okay finde aber man kriegt
und hätten nicht ganz so schön jetzt
zeige ich euch zwei varianten und zwar
gibt es was diese die presse
man kann hier ein bisschen extra drauf
machen bekommt man es leichter raus und
eine portion je nach größe hat es etwa
150 gramm kommt einfach mal ob papst
gepasst
ein bisschen mehr und das ganze wird
gedrückt
über steht nämlich einfach mit dem
finger weg schon jetzt zeige ich euch
noch ein zweites besser als bolt bin ich
mache von top konkurrenz
jetzt nehme ich noch ziemlich produkt
papier oder backpapier ist wie ihr so
eine partie presse nicht habt könnt ihr
den life ball einfach in die hand nehmen
den glücklichen vorher ein bisschen
zusammen
warum kommt das zwischen
butterbrotpapier und dann könnt ihr
einen gefäß nehmen ein schälchen ein
glas je nachdem wie groß der partie
haben möchte und kann das ganz
ausschließen
vielleicht habt ihr auch einen des
hering und könnte auch damit machen
im bisherigen hat ein bisschen spät zur
bekannten teilchen hier drücken
dies erscheint jetzt alles ein bisschen
groß aber das ist ja nur ein ganz
kleines bisschen auf dem grill
ich weiß jetzt fertig und werde sagen
morath gedacht den grill anschmeißen ich
mach das feuer
du machst das feuer denn sobald die
fertig sind können wir schon die partner
zusammen und man künstler auch noch ganz
großen nicht in den kühlschrank werden
genau das tun wir auch gut machen das 2
[Musik]
der bund hat sich natürlich gemacht der
grill ist schön heißt es glüht und jetzt
kann ich die partie strauß legen ich
hatte sie für eine halbe stunde im
gefrierfach und jetzt kommen die drauf
und werden je nach stärke von beiden
seiten etwa drei bis vier minuten
gegrillt finde ich frage ist ob das
supergrid 3400 mysteriöse und allem drum
und dran werden gar nicht schon ganz
ganz einfach einfach und stinknormal
holzkohlegrills 96 hoffen nach der
garzeit ledig dann noch eine scheibe
heimes käse drauf den haben wir am stück
gekauft und bin habe ich vorher einfach
zurecht geschnitten
der burger zusammengesetzt wir haben
auch die blogger brötchen ein bisschen
getröstet
fabian möchte lieber nicht getoastet
deswegen kriegst du deinen gleich
draußen am tisch denn wir werden euch
raus lassen aber für euch sind wir noch
mal hier
als erstes nehmen wird die chili sauce
fleisch burger drauf und dadurch jetzt
noch im heim missbraucht und der ist
wirklich besonderer wirklich in die
pflicht habe noch blüten obendrauf der
[Musik]
name der bank geführt um den eigenen
geschmack möchte verfälschen und mit so
warnten die wieder höhere einige
eingegangen
am besten
denn mora das ist ein chili burgers die
soße benutzt mein prinzip immer als
kleber grenze ja alles auseinander
willst du noch ein bisschen von mir
jetzt hast du rein stecken würde bei
hans im glück
damit bleibt offen lieber holt das ist
eine chemiefirma diesen bürger an
einsprüchen aus außen aus marktumfeld
gemacht so richtig konnten wir einige
probleme
das ist probieren er allen eine
landgemeinde einfach heim weiß rein wo
wir es gorris kräftig zu hören du hast
eine richtige kruste gemacht
blogger die weißen das wirkt er so eine
richtige küste auf den bürger brauch aus
dem paris der geheimnis darin liegt auch
beim grillen man kann die erst umdrehen
wenn sich eine kruste gebildet hat und
dann weiß man auch jetzt der perfekte
zeitpunkt auf dem grill jetzt kannst du
anheben und umdrehen
von daher die bürger uns eine richtig
geschmacksexplosion wird der heimische
käse große ja und wie die großen
zwiebeln morast und weise zugleich ist
ich weiß ganz schönes war es ganz
schlimm denn wir haben alle hunger und
müssen auch helaba
falls ihr das rezept auch gerne
nachmachen wollte und schaut auffällig -
blockte ich das jetzt noch mal alles
ganz genau und flüsse sind jetzt alle da
draußen ist richtig schönes wetter und
werden daraus machen und leckeren burger
essen also mehr nächsten mal sehen wie
weit ich weiß heute alle chancen alle
raus los und bei mir rat unterstützt
deinen eigenen bürger drauf machen
[Musik]